surprisingly
this story wasn't our lead from the
daily caller
biden admin plans on advising ukraine to
hand over territory to russia
this is an effective surrender
of
the conflict with russia in in ukraine
and i couldn't believe it when i read
this because the ap's headline i i
wonder if the daily caller has the link
to the associated press article the ap's
headline
did not actually i think we could pull
it up let's see what they have the
headline is
biden assures ukraine's leader of u.s
support to deter russia that's their
headline
and everybody sees that and they're like
okay sounds like we're good in eastern
europe right and then you scroll down in
the article and it says administration
officials have suggested that the us
will press ukraine to formally cede a
measure of autonomy within its eastern
donbass region which is now under de
facto control by russian-backed
separatists who rose up against kiev in
2014. so there is a group in eastern
ukraine that are backed by the russians
armed by the russians that view
themselves as completely separate want
to join russia and biden's response to
the buildup of troops by russia is let
him have it
that's crazy to me now i want to stress
this point
if this avoids u.s or eu conflict in the
region in a ground war probably a good
thing
but i suppose there's a line i don't
know where it is i agree with tucker we
shouldn't care about ukraine's borders
over our southern border which is porous
and busted
but i'm worried about another
afghanistan situation where joe biden
he's sitting there in the command seat
and then vladimir putin racks up 90 000
troops and biden goes
ukraine just just give it to him just
just just just give him the territory
and it's like here we go again could
there be a better way look under trump
this stuff wasn't happening and what did
trump do he sold weapons to ukraine and
putin backed off
he
putin takes uh crimea trump gets elected
putin backs off biden gets in putin
comes back and says i take
yeah i don't think biden's calling the
shots here um i i think there's um i
think putin's got compromise i think
there's a long geopolitical
neoconservative
pentagon establishment that does call
the shots and there's a lot of things
happening behind the scenes i wouldn't
be surprised if there's a trade-off here
if there's a bigger deal here um you
know the united states did give ukraine
2.5 billion dollars of of weaponry uh
they have been very active in the region
they have had success turning ukraine
that had its sphere of influence with
russia towards the european union so
this is a very complex picture it's
going to be interesting to see how it
unfolds from here obviously i prefer
diplomacy over hot war and i think we
should avoid hot war no matter what i
think the larger geo no matter what
you're uh well you know what i mean i i
think
we don't need neoconservatives in charge
threatening nuclear war and we have that
right now a part of the u.s government
threatening the russian government um i
don't think that helps the situation at
all so i think diplomacy is key here and
i think all of america's foreign policy
especially the way it's been run under
trump and now biden is shooting itself
on the foot and totally
counterproductive and also holds europe
in jeopardy since of course europe also
depends on a lot of russian oil and
energy that's being shipped towards it
right now so there's a lot of at stake
here um i still want to see the full
picture before uh jumping the gun and
understanding what's really happening
here what about you i i think this is a
your point is really really well taken
because there's there's all these
complex pieces there's also the piece of
like what are you know the central
european countries like poland you know
we were both we have both polish roots
what are they thinking as they're
looking you know poland wants to be this
big um you know basically ally to the us
and the u.s is basically doing things
like
encouraging
giving land to the russians that's like
a huge red flag for the polls i mean
this is the polls have been run
basically the russians have invaded many
times the germans have invaded many
times they're
you know expecting the next time yeah
well let me ask you guys though is there
is there any circumstance in which you
think it would be good for us troops to
be on the ground in ukraine
that's a very hard decision to make here
uh because of all the pieces here i i
would prefer it it doesn't happen i
would prefer diplomacy rule here i i
understand that you said that but my
question is you said you know um what do
you say at all costs or or i avoid war
i think we should avoid war at all costs
uh so so what if the cost is like uh
you know russia
overtly invades ukraine to kiev and
russian tanks are occupying the capital
of ukraine now i think it's the obvious
thing to point out we are not ukraine we
uh how much is our how much of it is it
our business to be like here's a country
that we're sort of friends with but
we're not even not even a part of the
nato alliance
should we intervene
yeah genocide what if the russians went
in and started executing families
children on the street lots of media
coverage of it are we supposed to go and
police the world at this point is the
time done for that i'm tired of putting
our people in harm's way i think there's
ways of appeasing both sides and and
calming the situation down without
reaching to those types of hyperbolic
levels now you made a good point poland
and other european countries are very
set against russia poland even uh is
building a military base called the
trump military base
very close to of course the russian
border um so so obviously there's a lot
of history there there's a lot of
turmoil there's a lot of conflict
there's a lot of bloodshed and it's just
it's just a horrible situation to deal
with that that we should avoid the the
bloodshed to me i'm gonna divert the
question a little bit because i don't i
don't fully know the answer to be
perfectly honest but i what i do know is
that some like what i believe is that
the russians basically putin they only
really understand strength as a response
and if you don't use that as is a
important tool of your diplomacy and
they are incredibly aware of the fact
that you will use whatever tool you have
if they cross the red line and it's a
real red line then they're going to
abuse that massively and i mean so this
you know this strategy this is what they
used in crimea right they moved
basically it's this kind of like gray
gray zone warfare right where they move
people in it's not really russian
there's kind of these people kind of
take over with the support and then
suddenly hey this is russia right
and so how many times do you let that
happen how do you know you need to
support your allies right right
and and that's and that's it i mean they
took crimea russia took it everyone you
know a lot of people believe i think
it's fair to say the elections in crimea
were bunk they came and said oh
everybody voted it's fine now crimea is
annexed by russia because russia wants
their warm-water port
but
they're there there are hard questions
about war right and i and the reason i
ask about what russia is doing and what
biden should do is i agree i don't want
ground war
i i think it may if biden is is telling
them look you're going to lose the
eastern front because we want to avoid
war it's like maybe avoiding war is
better and if the people in the eastern
front really do
want to be you know part of russia and
don't they have the the autonomy to
decide where who who they should be
governed by or what country they should
be a part of there's really tough
questions but the reason i ask about you
know war is because right now china's
got the weaker muslim camps and are we
declaring war on china are we going to
be like it's time to storm the beaches
of macau to like make our way to the you
know xinjiang you know region or
whatever
right now in
in you know in the us congress there's
huge efforts being made to water down
the provisions that would actually hold
uh you know china's activities in
xinjiang to account you know it's it's
it's it's fascinating so here's here's
this is the question right so i just i
was just uh you know speaking with uh
the former the former head of uh
human rights democracy and labor okay
for the state department under trump
um
uh robert destro so you know there's
probably you could say fairly there's
three genocides happening in china right
now there's the uyghur one the uyghur
tribunal just
reinforced that reality basically today
and then there's the the tibetans it's
the same model that's been happening for
a long time and and against the falun
gong practitioners as well you know an
attempt to eradicate you know an entire
group not necessarily by killing
everybody that's a later stage of
genocide but but through all sorts of
means including these forced
sterilizations um
etc and so on and so forth that's
actually interesting
there's there's this kind of other flip
side they're trying to actually prevent
people from getting sterilized in china
but that's that's a different topic
how do you deal this is the worst thing
this is what we agree the global
community the free world agrees it's the
absolute worst thing you can do
it's the worst thing right try to
eradicate entire groups of people china
is doing one for sure possib probably
three
and they they rag on tucker carlson for
saying why do we care about ukraine they
accuse him of defending putin that the
democrats act like vladimir putin is the
most powerful evil on the planet and and
russia's like almost nothing to us at
this point granted they got a lot of
nuclear weapons that i can get but
they've much smaller population and
china's massive and way more powerful
and more dangerous and committing
atrocities
and way more intertwined financially and
that's that's the other very serious
part of the puzzle right well china is
threatening america's hegemony and the
geopolitical picture between russia and
the united states is complicating that
and essentially allowing china to win
because they have russia which is going
to be aligning with them when they are
naturally competitors there's a lot of
thing that divides russia and china and
if geopolitically the united states
played their cards differently they
could have another strategic ally in the
region against their number one a lying
foe the number one competitor uh that
that most likely is going to create the
tessidius trap which we talk about on
the show a lot when thucydides yeah yeah
when an emerging power threatens a
current power there's a high likelihood
of war of conflict so i think on the
geopolitical scale that's a lot more
important especially with the picture of
taiwan
which the united states you know
geopolitically is kind of ignoring
almost outright
so to see this russian perspective
there's a way that there there should be
negotiations
we shouldn't just give anything up we
should be tough we should con you know
control our interests but we have to
also ask ourselves what were the
russians and chinese saying when the
united states was invading iraq when the
united states was invading afghanistan
were they saying hey if they attacked
this country this sovereign country that
had nothing to do with 9 11 like iraq
are we going to defend them when they're
doing a genocide on on their people
that's
and again i'm not making those arguments
but those were the arguments and
conversations that happened in their
countries and we have to understand that
those arguments if we're going to come
to a table to try to understand this
larger world picture uh that's unfolding
right now that's extremely complicated
that's a great point yeah the whole
united states took iraq china's going to
take taiwan russia takes
crime here so the whole idea of the
genocide convention right like i'm not a
fan of countries going out nation
building you know taking over areas us
any any kind of this is this is not this
is not good behavior
genocide is one of these things the
reason the genocide convention exists is
because there was a very serious
genocide the holocaust
right and people said
we we can't allow this to happen this is
something that we actually everybody
needs to get involved in
internationally when we see this
happening we really need to act right
because this is the worst thing humans
do to each other
right yeah
yeah there was uh we we talked about a
bit there was a post um james lindsay
made about what separates a
concentration camp from normal forms of
imprisonment and they said it's when
someone is detained without due process
they're taken from their home and
putting a camp without due process
exactly right the escalation on the
other hand is is you know
it depends right so that that's the idea
about what happened in in germany was
they were going and taking people and
then sending these camps which is
happening in a lot of different parts of
the world and it's not just china also a
lot of people you know a lot of the
bigger political uh establishment in
russia is saying well the united states
got libya they got syria they're
creating a domestic conflict in yemen
they're they they had their sphere of
influence in iraq and afghanistan
they're getting theirs we should get
ours so that's the type of conversations
that they're having and i think again
there's a lot of chess pieces on the
table but we have to reassess what we
know what we're told because there's a
totally different picture that we're not
seeing that we should see thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8pm and don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time